alright so the oscar snubz have been
nominated or nominations we don't want
to let's be a little PC here yeah their
nominations I agree with a lot I usually
conflict with most of the nominations in
Oscar season but there are some good
ones this time there are some obvious
Oscar snubs and that's what we're going
to talk about so the obvious elephant in
the room we're going to start off big
inceptions up for Best Picture
Christopher Nolan is not up for Best
Director
how can a director produce a movie it
gets people's imaginations thinking
people talk about the ending for months
they still talk about it people find it
intriguing it deals with the mind and
dreams it does it well and he wrote the
movie but yeah that guy I mean whatever
why cuz it is not a Georgia foals
yeah Inception is up for Best Picture
but honestly I hope it wins I really do
I don't know that it will and I've been
wrong about that kind of stuff before
but I always see this I always see a
bunch of movies out that I could see
yeah they're nominated for Oscars
because it appeals to you know Academy
people but inception people like this
snobby people kinda liked it which means
it's not good enough to win in a really
elite award ceremony I think the Academy
owes Christopher Nolan an Oscar for his
past like five movies but alas
Christopher Nolan snubbed for Best
Director and I'm pretty sure inception
is probably going to get snubbed for
Best Picture I hope not but we'll see
also snubbed Best Actor Leo DiCaprio
shutter island' wasn't one of my
favorite movies last year simply because
it was really predictable for me I knew
what the twist in the end was going to
be just from the trailer and when a
movie is that predictable I can't have
it be one of my favorites of the year
that being said Leo DiCaprio kicked ass
and his acting in the movie the guy
really always kicks ass and is acting
and he always gets snubbed he's been
nominated before but he has never won
maybe they're ahead of the curve maybe
they're like or we're going to snub him
for the win anyway so why even nominate
him maybe he banged the daughter of a
member of the Academy like back in his
Titanic days who knows someone's got to
be pissed at him but Leonardo DiCaprio
absolutely kicked ass and could have
gone toe-to-toe with anyone in 2010 for
Best Actor and snubbed for best
animation where is tangled I mean 2010
had a lot of animations and of all the
animations that came out three are
nominated two of which I've heard of and
of those two they absolutely deserve to
be there yeah for sure but come on
people are hailing tangulls like the
return of the Disney Princesses and
they're putting it on par with like the
Disney classics now no Oscar we think
only three deserve it come on for the
chemistry of awesome
dudes and hot blondes tangled or even
Guardians of Ga'Hoole I thought it was
awesome it was badass
a little badassery who needs it that's
not memorable at all because we're the
Academy and it is not intuitive fall and
this next movie was snubbed for
something visual or audio either visual
effects sound effects sound editing
something visual or audio somewhere
should have been given to Scott Pilgrim
but now sound editing let's nominate
True Grit I'm not a sound guru or
anything like that but did True Grit
really have better sound editing than
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world those sounds
were awesome I was in the theater it
sounded badass I mean love the movie or
hate the movie I almost dare you to pick
a movie that had a more unique visual or
audio spectrum than Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world and shouldn't uniqueness be
rewarded no not in the eyes of the
Academy why cuz it is not a Georgia
Foles
and as for Tron Legacy I thought the
surroundings like the entire environment
was really good special effects wise
clue not so much that's probably why I
got snubbed cuz they didn't really
refine clue but the soundtrack seriously
you're not going to nominate that the
soundtrack was not only badass not only
do I have it in my car right now but it
was half of what made the movie half the
badassery from the movie came from the
soundtrack give it up to Daft Punk for
that original score and of course there
is a collection of shouldn't have been
nominated like hereafter for special
effects
why is hereafter nominated for special
effects but that's tsunami Singh yeah
the tsunami scene was really impressive
I'll give the tsunami scene that that
one scene but in that skyline had more
impressive special effects more often in
the movie movie yeah but I just
want fair to be fair if hereafter is
nominated for that one scene skyline
should probably be nominated for all
those scenes
neither movie was good skyline was worse
but it fair is fair in the end there are
some justifiable nominations I'll give
the Academy that but there are some
hardcore snobs this year and I know I
can't get to everything you guys have to
feel the thirst nubs that I didn't
mention now so here's your chance
comment below let everyone know what you
thought got snubbed in the Oscar
nominations so hey just got brighter and
stay tuned for what we're calling the
Justice League or the Avengers of Oscar
predictions me schmoes know Tom chattel
bash and fury of the film fan are all
getting together and doing a
collaborative video that should be out
in the next few days as to what our
predictions are for the Oscars the main
categories Best Picture Best Director
Best Actor Best Actress Best Supporting
Actor and Best Supporting Actress to
check for that in the next few days I'll
put an annotation
there when it comes out and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]